New Delhi is making sure this part of
Indian administered Kashmir is ready to
receive diplomats from the G20 Nations
but it's also facing allegations that
it's whitewashing human rights abuses
and the suppression of freedom in the
disputed Himalayan territory
holding the G20 conference here has a
political context to it the meaning of
this event is to prove to the people of
Kashmir that internationally Kashmir
issue has been buried forever this is
one of the achievements of the G20
conference
the region is known for its natural
beauty and India wants to boost tourism
and investment here some in the area
hope the summit will help do that
is
tourism and livelihood for all those who
are associated with the tourism sector
but you know it all depends on the
Kashmir situation that should remain
good on the situation on Kashmir what
can we say you know what the situation
Kashmir is like
India holds a chair of the G20 and in
the run-up to the main Summit in New
Delhi in September is holding a series
of meetings across this territory
Jammu and Kashmir
was is will always be a part of India
and the G20 meetings are held in all the
Indian States and union territories so
it is completely natural that it is held
there
but it's also been the scene of protests
attacks against Indian soldiers and a
recent internet blackout India wants to
show normality but for those who live
here it's anything but business as usual
for people of smear it would have meant
something had there been normal
situation over here
no normalcy does not mean normalcy of a
graveyard where you have restrictions on
media restrictions on people people
languishing in jails and all this
and at the same time you want a project
to the world that it is normal
security is tight after five Indian
soldiers were killed by suspected
separatists last month Indian
administered Kashmir remains one of the
most militarized zones in the world and
human rights organizations have
described new delhi's policies as
repressive and criticize its Detention
of Human Rights activists and
journalists
and that's leaving many to wonder
whether India can convince diplomats and
the world that the situation here is
normal